here we go one two three go
if i can't talk verbally to you
my music can
[Music]
oh that's dope
it's all about your energy what you put
into the record
[Music]
the beat has to be infectious first
you're going to learn about filling
vocals software
we're going to talk about some of my
hits daryl if you showed us his three
instruments
you're going to learn about how i can
take something simple and make it
complex
you don't need a big old studio to do
what you need to do you can do this on
your own
if you have your computer and your mic
watch this
yeah yeah i start from scratch
making a beat yeah with my mouth
melody
then i can duplicate it on a drum
machine
[Music]
this would be the idea to use it as a
template and create around it
hey see the feeling is getting there now
i have to go in the booth
it's no thought process it's all about
having fun that's dope
you see what the feeling made me do
that's what it should do to you
[Music]
i want to give all the knowledge that i
can give that's what i'm here on earth
to do we have so much available to us
that it's all in you in what you want to
do
if you love it that much it's gonna
happen
i'm timbaland and this is my master
[Music]
class
[Music]
you